l'image en premier ministre qui commence
par dire il faut qu'on fasse des
économies partout les caisses de l'état
sont pour ainsi dire vides et qui
dépensent 350000 euros
ça faisait ça ne passe pas un prêt
commun des mortels qui se serrent la
ceinture qui est pas l'argent ils disent
mais comme ça se fait que il peut dire
ok il lui revient d'urgence de nouvelle
calédonie je ne peux pas prendre un
avion militaire parce que c'est
inconfortable jeune femme allongée
je suis désolé ça ne passe pas et je
peux vous dire une chose qu'ici c'était
en grande bretagne cette histoire auprès
d'un ministre pour un ministre n'importe
quel personnage important dans le
gouvernement
ça ne passera pas parce que une fois que
la presse tabloïd saisi d'une affaire
pareille la personne est morte et
politiquement mots et sera obligé à mon
avis de jetter l'épongé
donc c'est un calcul à mauvais calcul et
ça me laisse l'impression toujours que
quand on est pas il le mini quand on
n'est pas un homme est ministre on dit
tous vos une chose